these are the signs you might want to
look out for that you might be again for
example in high school you were voted
most likely to make a citizen's arrest
you park in the handicapped spot because
of a gluten intolerance you threatened
to call immigration during a pedicure
when you're at the baseball stadium and
your team loses you demand to speak to
the manager when Samuel Jackson says
what's in your wallet you pepper spray
the TV that's a definite so you go on a
Facebook rant about how the Asian
section in the supermarket keeps getting
bigger you repeatedly cancel ubers until
you get a driver with a normal name
and when a friend says this is my
fiancee you say this is America dammit
speak English
you